THEN-PRESIDENT OBAMA'S DECISION
TO IMPLEMENT DACA WAS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL WAS ERRONEOUS.
THAT WILL BE PART BY THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
ONE KEY SENATOR SAYS WHEN IT
COMES TO IMMIGRATION REFORM, IT
IS THE PRESIDENT'S WAY OR NO WAY
AT ALL.
THIS COMES AS THE WHITE HOUSE
UPS THE PRESSURE ON SENATE
DEMOCRATS DURING WHAT IS
SUPPOSED TO BE A RARE OPEN
DEBATE ON THIS SUBJECT.
CHIEF CONGRESSIONAL
CORRESPONDENT MAKE A MANUAL
TELLS US WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW.
>> THAT EXPIRES BEGINNING
MARCH 5TH, SO WE KNOW WE HAVE A
DEADLINE.
THE PRESIDENT HAS OFFERED A
GENEROUS PROPOSAL.
>> REPUBLICANS FAVOR A PLAN
OFFERED BY THESE SIX G.O.P.
SENATORS, WHICH IS THE
LEGISLATIVE VERSION OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S PROGRAM,
ILLUMINATES THE VISA LOTTERY AND
ENDS CHAIN MIGRATION.
>> THERE IS NO REASON WHY
REASONABLE PEOPLE IN CONGRESS
CAN'T GET TOGETHER AND GET
BEHIND THIS.
>> GET THE DAY AFTER VOTING 97-1
TO START DEBATE IN THE SENATE,
THE TOP LEADERS COULD NOT AGREE
ON HOW TO BEGIN.
>> LET'S GET THIS DEBATE STARTED
ON THE RIGHT FOOT, SO I OBJECT
TO THE LEADER'S REQUEST.
>> THAT LED SOME REPUBLICANS TO
CONCLUDE DEMOCRATS DON'T WANT A
SOLUTION.
THEY PREFER A 2018 CAMPAIGN
ISSUE.
TODAY, THE MAJORITY LEADER SAID
HE WANTS TO GET SOMETHING DONE
THIS WEEK.
>> THERE IS NO REASON, NO REASON
NOT TO COME TOGETHER AND GET A
SOLUTION THIS WEEK.
THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON
ENDLESSLY.
THEY SHUT DOWN THE GOVERNMENT
OVER THIS.
>> THE DEMOCRATIC REP BLAMED THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> IT WAS THE PRESIDENT WHO
ENDED UP ENDING THE DACA PROGRAM
EFFECTIVE MARCH 5TH OF THIS YEAR
AND CHALLENGING CONGRESS TO
RESPOND.
>> THE SENATE DEMOCRATIC LEADERS
SAID COOPERATION WILL BE
NECESSARY.
>> I THINK THE SOONER THE BETTER
>> I THINK THE SOONER THE BETTE
BETTER, AND IF WE CAN COME UP
WITH A BIPARTISAN COMPROMISE
THAT LOOKS LIKE IT IS RIGHT IN
THE BALLPARK, LET IT RIP, LET'S
GO.
>> BUT A KEY CONSERVATIVE SAYS
THE PRESIDENT'S PROPOSAL IS THE
BEST AND FINAL OFFER.
>> THEY DO, IN FACT, WANT TO
UPHOLD THE PROMISES THAT THEY
MADE TO PROTECT THESE DEMOCRATS.
>> THEY SAY IT IS EITHER THE
PRESIDENT'S OFFER OR A MORE
CONSERVATIVE OPTION FROM THE
HOUSE JUDICIARY -- POTENTIALLY